[Music]
okay we got another white
fine
let's go e4
knight f3
and we continue
to play the
fortnite scotch
continue to play the four night scotch
so far
we've performed very well with it
and and so far we haven't faced anybody
who's gone for the main line which of
course is bishop before in this position
or bishop c5
most people below 1500 tend to take the
knight on d4 but this is around the
level
no still still knight takes d4 not a
good move as we've discussed on several
occasions guys uh because once the queen
enters the center
and a lot of people here play c5 like
this is like incredibly common move
at at you know steven 1600 and below
because it's this idea that if you
attack the queen you're doing something
good but as i've said you have to
divorce yourself
from the notion that simply threatening
the queen is a good idea on its own
basis you know it has to be doing
something else d6 though is a better
move d6 is a nice move
this is the lesser evil because it stops
us from playing e5
and here we should make an important
decision about where we want to castle
um both
ways of playing are totally fine
but
in this game i just feel like playing a
little bit more positionally so
i feel like castling short today
which essentially means that we should
start by developing this bishop
let's castle king's side and let's play
positionally where should we go with the
bishop on f1 who can tell me
what the most natural the nicest square
for the bishop is in such positions
yeah so there's two options bishop d3
definitely is possible but i personally
prefer bishop c4
i prefer bishop c4 why do i say that
because the pawn on e4 is it's it's in
it protected enough times right it's
protected already twice you don't really
need this bishop to be protecting it
again i think the bishop is doing a
little bit better on this diagonal
instead
bishop b5 check would be an empty move
because of c6 this should be five check
just runs into c6 and that we haven't
gained anything
okay castles
now as for the other bishop this is a
bit of a trickier question
as for the other bishop this is a
trickier question
because you could essentially make a
case that none of the squares on this
diagonal are all that great you could
play bishop g5 that's obviously a
reasonable move nothing wrong with it
but it's you know it doesn't pin the
knight
big deal right bishop f4 kind of bites
on granite
bishop e3 you could say well that's okay
but it's a little bit bland and it also
walks into knight g4 in some situations
so is there an alternative like if we
don't like any of these squares
is there hypothetically something else
we could do
i don't like bishop d2 that's like
that's it's just really passive right
and it blocks the d file presumably
we'll want to put a rook on d1 at some
point
let's see
let's fianchetto
don't forget about the fianchetto and
don't feel like the fianchetto
is only for
the nimzo larsen right if you don't do
it on move one you can never do it
fianchettoing is a legitimate way of
developing your pieces of developing
your bishops
okay bishop b6
now do we need to react to this should
we take on e6 or should we simply
proceed
with the fiance or maybe we should drop
the bishop back to d3
what do you guys think
this is a pretty slam dunk question yeah
we should just ignore
we we definitely shouldn't trade because
that gives him more control over the
center and it gives our opponent the
f-file
so bishop b2
you know the the the instinct should be
to keep the tension not to trade
the instinct should be to ignore rook e8
okay
now we have many good moves we have a
great position where we're more space
and we have a couple of approaches we
can take
but the approach i like is just just to
keep improving our position to make
natural good moves
and ultimately
uh to detect the moment when we should
take more concrete action as we did in
the previous game
so
how should we position our rooks well
this is again a very easy question
rooks on d1 and e1 is the traditional
way
of playing in such positions let's start
with rook ad1 it doesn't really matter
you could also start with a rook fe one
obviously we take with the queen not
with the pawn
and the moment when i've taken to the
queen i've noticed that there is an
x-ray against black screen now there's
nothing i can do about it now right
i've just noticed that i made a mental
note to myself just to make sure that i
don't miss tactics related to that x-ray
okay
in addition to rook fe1 we can also
start pushing the f bond we can
definitely play f4 but again i want to
play as simple as possible this game and
see where that strategy takes us at work
fe1
and the other thing we haven't gotten a
chance to do yet which i really want to
is create some luft with the move h3 i
want to create some loop given that
there's a pretty non-zero possibility
that the center opens up you could just
see that things are starting to
percolate in the center e5 has become a
possible idea
it would be very very nice if we had a
little bit of lift so we didn't have to
worry about it okay
now this is an instructive moment
because i think a lot of you
probably look at this move and say oh no
black is heading for e5 this is
something we should prevent
so perhaps we should play f4
but you know in fact we don't have to
and this is exactly the point i've been
making
several times here which is that
your opponent threatening your queen is
not inherently dangerous yeah let's
imagine that black plays knight e5
you move your queen back to e2
then you casually play f4 and chase the
knight away from e5 it's really not a
big deal
really not a big deal
but f4 is good as a standalone move i
like f4 we're going to play f4 we're
gonna play it but i want us to be
playing this move not because it's so
important to prevent knight e5 but
because we're expanding on the king's
side that's why we're playing that move
we're expanding on the king side we're
controlling squares it's not because
we're so afraid of 95 as long as we
understand that i'm fine with us playing
it
okay now our reaction to this move is
pretty
uh is is generally to play a4 and
prevent b5
um and i think this is no exception
let's try to let's try to be as
prophylactic as possible our opponent
playing well rook c8
okay
well what should we do now f4 has
already created loft we already have a
little bit of loft on f2
so we should probably
start assembling our pieces
in preparation for a kingside attack
so a lot of you are proposing knight t5
not a good move guys because black just
plays c6 and chases the knight away from
d5
common mistake
right it's tempting to put the knight
into the center but we shouldn't do that
just yet
what i prefer is a rook lift i prefer
work lift either rook e3 rook g3 or d3
rook g3 both would have been fine
i feel like this is a little bit better
though because i want to keep the other
rook
on d1 because it x-rays the queen i want
us to maintain as many
tactical properties of the position as
possible queen h4 good move
yeah and
this is a case in point now a rook on d1
which is free and currently doesn't have
an assignment
can shift over to f1 in order to guard
the f4 pawn
does that make sense
and now in addition to playing rook g3
which is still possible how could we
where where else could we go
what else could we do on the king side
well we could play rook g3 that's
what our plan was initially but notice
the queen on h4 right it's right in our
face
okay b5 forget everything i said let's
focus on the move that i don't
understand that at all
that just seems like a weird blunder
upon we just take it okay
knight b6 okay that was the idea but
again this is not scary just attacks our
queen we move our queen back and
that's it
now where should we put our queen this
is a bit of a tricky question
i like the d3 square for two main
reasons the first is that it's a nice
centralized spot for the queen right
it's a nice spot it's in the center
and it holds everything together but the
other reason i like queen d3 who can
name the other reason i'm noticing a
potential tactical reason which is way
far in the future but maybe not so far
in the future
it's yeah it's it's sort of staring down
the h7 pawn and you can imagine that if
we go rook h3 which
i think we could even play in this
position we're not but it's something we
could consider
you know after the queen moves we could
go e5 and then we'll have a mate threat
now instead i would prefer to take on b5
let's just secure our extra pawn
and then we'll start worrying about
continuing the attack in addition part
of the reason i took with the knight and
not with the queen
is that i noticed a very very powerful
maneuver that this knight could embark
on
what am i talking about where would it
go what's the destination
and
you know this is a square that you
should always be looking at in such
positions because it's really the ideal
square for the night i've said this
before
f5 let's go
san francisco frankfurt frankfurt f5
international airport
simple maneuver old as the hills we're
going to f5 or hitting g7 and here's
some very important thing to understand
guys does g6 prevent knight f5
does the move g6 prevent knight f5
because i know that some of you might be
worried about this prospect
the answer is obviously no it does not
why doesn't it because after g6 knight
f5
g takes f5 well we had rook g3 and that
is totally devastating i'll show this
after the game on the board
okay knight f5
of course d takes e4 we take the queen
with check and i expected you to spot
this
and that's it we are the stage is set
now it's time for decisive action
okay very our play should be very
logical here we haven't done anything
tactically crazy just yet
we d7
okay
now there are multiple ways that we
could win this game multiple
um and there are you know several
tactical approaches to take here
but let's try to play
in an aesthetically pleasing way and in
an effective way
so
i think you guys might be a little bit
overwhelmed by the abundance of tactical
ideas available to us on the king side
but one very important idea to
understand here is first of all rook g3
is the most obvious move right just to
get the rook to g3
and rook two three is winning g3 is
winning because
after rook g3 g6
right
what can we do what is the crushing move
after g6
knight h6 black didn't play king h8 here
knight h6 jack black is under no
obligation to take the knight
queen d4 jake got it rook g3 g6 queen d4
and threats along the long diagonal
aren't stopped
but
we can take the idea of rook g3 we can
convert it into something a little bit
nicer we can take it and convert it into
something a little bit nicer we can
start
by playing bishop takes g7 we can start
by throwing in this move
and after bishop takes g7 then and only
then do we go rook g3 okay and that's
crushing because the bishop is
indefensible
unless he wants to give away his queen
which is fine by me
and once we once we get our rook to g7
the combination of the knight and the
rook and the queen on d3 which is ready
to swing to the king side there is going
to be a mating combination there i
haven't seen it just yet but i trust
that it it exists
i trust that it exists
and i'll talk more about this after the
game if you're feeling a little confused
like how did i
what am i doing
you know don't don't worry about it i'll
address this afterwards so rook takes g7
check and i'm really hoping for king f8
because it'll allow us yes it'll allow
us to demonstrate a very typical but
very pretty decisive combination which
one am i referring to
yeah rook g8 the rook sacrificed
forcing the king onto g8
i don't know exactly what it's called
actually this isn't really a deflection
sacrifice i guess it is a deflection
sacrifice you're
you're forcing the king onto g8 where it
will be checkmated with the queen
traveling to g7
yeah remember this concept this is a
very classic classic
attacking idea
okay
simple attack
nice ending
let's delve into the game
so
i'm gonna go very quickly through the
opening again knight takes d4 is is a
mistake we've gone over this many many
times
uh you guys know that bishop b4 is the
traditional move with bishop c5
being another viable way of handling
this position
uh but d6 to our opponent's credit is a
lot better than c5
which creates
massive weaknesses in the center
and c5 you might remember that our queen
belongs on a4 in this position to stop
d6 and now white simply threatens to
play e5
okay
so d6
we get our bishop out
um bishop e7 castle's castles
and now we decided to fianchetto our
bishop and of course the fact that the
queen is on d4 is a big
influence
on this decision
because once we get our bishop
fianchettoed we are going to have a
direct x-ray onto the g7 pawn
and the moment the knight on f6
disappears we will have
obviously
uh tactical ideas connected with that
okay so bishop b6 bishop b2 keeping the
tension rook e8
uh i don't know if i fully explained why
this is beneficial to black right
there's two main real the file is less
important right the f file is not
occupied by either side it's really the
fact that the pawn guards the d5 square
this is what i don't like about that
right we can really never play knight d5
again and
black also opens up space on the king
side so the rook for instance can move
back to f8 and it can move to f7 and
guard the g7 pawn against any
combinations related to this battery
right so instead we just improve our
position
we continue improving we play f4 not
really to prevent knight e5 but just to
expand
a6 a4 stopping b5
rook c8
welcome to rook lift land
now rook f1 to defend the pawn on f4
and b5 is sort of panic our opponent
panicked here
if he wanted to prepare b5 that is not a
bad idea but he should go c6
and by the way guys a lot of you made
this mistake knight d5 be careful about
these types of moves right
i understand the instinct to centralize
your knight is a very good one but just
make sure that you're you're checking to
see whether your opponent can chase that
knight away
you know don't just throw throw a piece
into the center see if that square is
stable
it's super important if white's black's
pawn was on c5 then obviously knight t5
would be amazing
okay
so
takes knight b6 queen back to d3 staring
down the h7 pawn knight takes b5
okay um
knight comes to d4 and this is
the juiciest part of the game so g6
we
throw the knight onto f5 anyway
g takes f5 rook g3 check this isn't mate
on in one and black and stave off mate
with bishop g7 but you can take with
either piece here
and you know what's really cool
if you take with a bishop and black
takes on e4 with the queen
who can give me the mating sequence and
if you paid careful attention to how we
checkmated him during the game you
should see this quickly this is exactly
the same idea but with the bishop rather
than with the knight
with the bishop rather than with the
knight bishop f6
yeah and now rather than a rook on g3 we
need a queen on g3 so that it can give a
mate on g7
boom
in the game we had a knight on f5 both
of these pieces are fulfilling exactly
the same role
that is defending g7
so
similarities and patterns
you can already see that bearing fruit
so instead d5
knight f5 and now we are staring at the
g7 pawn now first thing to get out of
the way knight h6 is a bad move
and when you're attacking you can never
assume that your opponent is going to
take pieces that you sacrifice
after king 86 i simply don't see a
follow-up folks i mean maybe i'm missing
something but
f7 is defended now your knight looks
kind of dumb on h6 and you've actually
helped black's king get to a safer
square that's the tragedy of this move
is that you've helped black's king move
to a safer square even though it's
the pawn on g7 is pinned
the spawn is not not the worst pawn in
the world it's defended by the bishop
you need to maintain your knight on f5
because it pressures the g7 pawn
okay now the second
idea is to play rook g30 this is to
complete the rook left
and after g6 i mentioned that queen d4
is win is winning and it is
it creates
totally crushing threats queen h8 is
made
f6
queen takes f6
resignable
um
but
there's this idea of sort of changing up
the move order right you can take on g7
first
and then get the rook to g3
and then get the rook to g3 and i'm sure
that i could even find games with this
kind of idea like you sack on g7 first
and then you complete the rook lift
let me see if i can
dig up an example here
in this position um
not
famous players but correspondents
what do you think white started with and
it's a slightly different version of the
combination don't don't just try to like
you know one for one this like it's
that's the whole point that's why chess
is a hard game now you might notice that
the rook on e1 is attacked but white
ignores that threat
and creates a much stronger threat
instead of moving this rook passively to
e2
white plays bishop takes h6
black dutifully grabs the rook on e1 and
here white applies the concept we have
just talked about right a lot of you
would be tempted to go knight f5 here
but if you go to nf5 immediately black
goes g6 and black defends
so you have to change up the the order
of operations what should you do first
what did white do first before going 905
right this exact same concept
first you take on g7
and then you go knight f5 right and now
black can't stop the rook from
infiltrating to g7 the best that black
can do here to avoid getting checkmated
and just like in our game just like in
our game he could have gotten checkmated
like this
right that's exactly
how we finished the game but
in this game black correctly played
queen f6
essentially giving up the queen but this
is completely winning for white white
has this queen a knight pair
the knight the other knight is coming
out to f5 and white just has a gazillion
extra pawns
and black has a wide open king white
went on to win in about 20 more moves
the rest of the game is that interesting
another example
this is a swedish gm brunel
game of swedish gm
um this position okay so you can see
some of the elements in common right
notice the elements that are in common
with our game what do you see well you
might notice that there's a knight on d4
right you might notice that there's a
rook on d3 there's a bishop on f4 guinea
two right white's assembled all these
pieces and they all aim at the king side
so you look at this for a couple of
seconds and the first move that comes to
mind to me
is to complete the rook left with rook
g3
but as we already know here black can
make the move g6 and
this bishop on f8 can try to reposition
to g7 and black and try his best
to hold to hold on for dear life
but white makes an incredibly smart
smart move here it's a tactic it's
pretty simple who sees it what does
white start with
what does white start with here
doesn't start with rook g3 doesn't start
with knight f5 he starts with bishop
takes h6 straight away
the point is that if g takes h6 you give
a check and black is busted because if
you cover with the bishop
then of course knight f5 is winning but
queen g4 is mating
and queen g4 is also what happens after
kha this is just so one sided i mean
look at this
queen g8 is the mate thread and if you
move the bishop then you relinquish the
g7 square ah
you know common occurrence
so
black goes d6 tries his best to distract
him white's not distracted rook g3de and
now we already know the drill knight f5
allows g6
therefore bishop takes g7 first
then knight f5 and that's it rook takes
g7 is coming black had to go f6 and give
up the queen
but
the game lasted only five more moves
so
you know important attacking
concept motif whatever you want to call
it
but it but it is
and uh very similar to what we do bishop
takes g7 now it should make a lot more
sense hopefully now that you've seen
these examples rook g3 and
we're gonna now black could have played
f6 and probably should have played f6
just like
that 2300 did and
very similar kind of thing where we're
up a queen and a million pawns and this
is an easy win
all right don't be afraid to convert
your attack into a big material
advantage that doesn't mean you did
something wrong that often is the best
way to continue
against best defense
yeah knight g7 also possible also very
much possible i think probably an
alternative
probably an alternative but i i think
the knight on f5 is just a better
attacker in general than the bishop
no i look these games up
yeah and if king h8 this was more
resilient of a defensive move
oh my god but we have a
oh we have a gorgeous mating sequence
here we have a gorgeous mating sequence
who sees it
oh my god this would have been even
nicer
this would have been such a nice way to
end the game now a lot of you are
probably noticing queen h3 not the best
move
not the best move
because black can hold on with queen
takes f5 and of course black is totally
lost here but the game goes on
instead
instead you take take on h7 then you
play quinn h3
now if the king drops back then
everything is easy
right queen g4 queen g7 is made this is
easy
what about king g6
because now if you play queen g4 the
king i'm not sure there's mate here the
king escapes through f6 to e6
but we have a really really nice idea
let's play queen h6
king takes f5
g4
keep forcing the king further and
further down the primrose path and now
queen g5 queen g3 is made
and isn't that nice king ends up on h3
that's just what happens when you have
the right attacking ingredients in place
when you have such an abundance of
attackers you can afford to sack
all most if not all of them and still
deliver checkmate
oh yeah queen g525 is even faster very
good catch even faster queen g525 and
perhaps even nicer made in the center of
the board
beautiful
also also mate
um
awesome
awesome stuff good catch
okay well that would have been even
nicer but our opponent i i didn't see
that during the game i only saw that
just now he played king f8 but now rook
chief is winning
okay uh that was a nice attack that was
you know one of the first times we we
really won a game with a sustained
attack that lasted more than you know
two or three moves
notice the ingredients we started by
lifting our rook up we patiently
assembled our pieces we used a maneuver
to get our knight to an ideal square and
then when we had the pieces locked in
place we looked for concrete sacrifices
and ideas
okay
i think this is a great spot to end we
went a little bit longer than expected
but
now it's time for me to go to bed
all right guys thank you for hanging out
and everybody for the support i'll see
you tomorrow bye everybody
[Music]